all right okay i can now see why so many
of you have been excited for me to get
to this arc this
is without question the strongest arc of
hunter hunter and one that left me with
my jaw
on the floor a number of times every
series has their iconic moments dragon
ball had goku versus frieza one piece
has shiva the archipelago and hunter
hunter i now realize has
this
in this video the material i'll be
covering is both thoughtfully composed
to highlight the series greatest
strengths while also single-handedly
executing upon
long built up previously established
plot points and overarching themes
creating something unlike anything i've
ever seen from a manga producing
character writing that feels so
incredibly brutal and
honest that i honestly couldn't help but
shed a tear for all those involved
and this is only the first 33 or so
chapters
however while this arc gripped me like
none other before it it also filled me
with tremendous sadness the moment i
began my journey
through its opening pages and i'm not
talking about the story
this is an arc i'm sure you've all been
waiting for me to cover and i am so
thrilled to say that thus far
i've loved it so let's dive head first
into this creepy unsettling and
existential nightmare
that is hunter hunter's chimera and
[Music]
[Applause]
ark
[Music]
if it's okay with you guys i sort of
want to kick off this video with a
somber and
rather serious subject as i have already
mentioned in the opening this week's
material brought to light something that
deeply saddened me in part due to the
pervasive despair that coats the pages
of its narrative but
also due to one undeniable issue
lingering in the background of indeed
this arc
and the entire series yoshihiro
togashi's
dwindling health and output something
you may have noticed in my videos is
that i haven't drawn attention to or
outlined a single one of hunter hunter's
most commonly known issues
its seemingly never ending string of
increasingly long hiatuses
the bad art that accompanies it on
occasion and
even the vitriolic or disparaging
comments the whiter anime community
loves hunter hunters
and sometimes even tagashi's way because
of them
for the purposes of this video i was
required to read volumes 18 to 21 of the
manga
written and illustrated by tagashi
himself from as early as volume 1 it
became tradition for tagashi to address
his audience with either a joke of some
description
or some important news from his life in
these volumes opening pages
in prior volumes these segments have
been a way for tagashi to communicate
with us
about a fun holiday he recently returned
from it acted as a place for him to
announce his marriage to the woman he
loves and even the birth of their first
child together
it's all been positive and normally this
is something i look forward to reading
before i've opened any of the volumes
throughout my read-through however when
i opened
these specific volumes the messages from
tagashi painted a
very different and very sad picture
volume 18 i had to redraw a lot of this
volume too
volume 19. this volume was even more
work
volume 20. with volume 21
reading like a plea for help or at the
very least understanding
i'm just barely getting by for those of
you that
aren't aware of this up until the
beginning of the chimera ants arc hunter
hunter while missing certain weeks here
and there was predominantly a consistent
weekly series in shouldn't jump like any
other
its art with very few exceptions was
pristine regardless of whether you were
reading the original magazine
publication weekly or
the compiled volume later however as
tagashi waded into the chimera ants arc
the breaks between releases became
larger and larger due to serious health
complications tagashi suffered with this
resulted in the majority of the chapters
hitting weekly show and jump in an
entirely
unfinished state sketches missing panels
descriptive dialogue in place of art
these unfinished pages have spread all
over the internet and have severely
misled fans
about what the hunter hunter manga
actually looks like when i began this
series i was flooded with messages from
people attempting to dissuade me from
reading the manga
as my primary source entirely based on
the idea that these unfinished pages
represent what the manga has to offer
but the thing is
i'm reading the collected volumes of
this series and with each
new release tagashi has gone back over
and redrawn or touched up
all of the unfinished chapters despite
his chronic health conditions tagashi
took the time to finish
or redraw all of them and they look
absolutely
amazing it's a meme on this channel to
say things are the best yet but
the content in these finnish volumes is
genuinely some of his absolute
best work and not even remotely in the
realm of novel or scribbles
over my career as a review channel
whenever i began a new story there were
always those that would disparage me
from choosing to read the manga over the
anime every community has its own
challenges but
in the case of hunter hunters it was the
widespread misinformation concerning
hunter hunter's manga
i received hundreds of posts showing me
the bad artwork and citing that as a
reason to not read the manga primarily
and yet now
having arrived at the quote bad bits
over halfway through the series
i found that not only have i never
encountered a single bad or unfinished
product
but it's also been stunningly beautiful
i'm well aware that i'm not 100 up to
date yet and
if i get there and find that there are
legitimate issues i will acknowledge and
talk about them but thus far
over 20 volumes deep the rhetoric that
hunter hunter's manga is ugly or lacking
in any way is a misguided exaggeration
that flies in the face of tagashi's hard
work
now i'm not going to drone on any
further instead i will let tagashi's
work speak for itself throughout this
video
oh yeah by the way did i mention that
the beginning of this arc is incredibly
weird and sort of
cheesy as mentioned above the ark is
filled with really interesting and
beautiful imagery yes and while the star
of this arc is no different it is set
apart almost immediately from the other
arcs in this series
between every story so far the hunter
exams the lumber family arc the
heavens arena arc the york new and greed
island arcs
hunter hunter has almost made it its
life's mission to tie every single arc
seamlessly together allowing for the
story to naturally flow into the next
however the chimera
ant arc does not do this or at least it
doesn't as much as the others and
as a result of that for the first few
chapters of this arc i was really
worried that this highly praised arc was
going to be disappointing
spoilers it wasn't largely the beginning
portion of the story looks as though it
was shot like one of those
cheesy old-timey monster movies from the
30s and 40s complete with authentic
giant chimera and bug monster one of the
biggest revelations at this time
was that of this character the chimera
and monster
while unique it didn't strike me
initially as being designed to emote in
any meaningful way and
if i'm being honest unlike the driving
forces behind many
of the prior arcs we didn't have a tie
to this arc's antagonist in any
meaningful way
or at least not in a way that we were
aware of which i think
largely contributed to this arc slow
start for me predominantly
but that's not even to say that its
weakest part didn't have
amazing and touching moments
establishing a character's defining
actions like a young boy trying to
defend his little sister from this
chimera ant monster helped to establish
the antagonistic force of the story as
well as
set the tone for the coming conflict now
this introduction
was fine but compared to the other acts
it felt lukewarm and the last thing i
wanted was to watch a story
waste kite's reintroduction to the
series seeing how hyped i was
having just finished greed island and
for those of you who haven't seen or
read this arc
in short it might sound like the
antagonistic and protagonistic forces
have
nothing to do with each other and in a
way you're right gold and kilowatt are
just after teaming up with kaid and his
crew as they engage in
ecological activity all the while on the
other side of the world
the chimera and queen slowly begins to
kill animals
and eventually people trying to grow her
family with the goal of one day
in the not so distant future of giving
birth to
the chimera and king and that's the
beginning of this arc in a nutshell
really
one plotline that while cued doesn't
have any particular direction and
another that feels like a
run-of-the-mill monster movie
both fine yes but not at all connected
however
that doesn't last and what comes next is
the
absolute best or most raw material i've
yet seen produced by hunter hunter
this is where the business of the story
kicks off and
boy does it never stop the action in
this portion of the story is the
strongest in the entire series and
i'm speaking from a manga perspective
here people can give the initially
released sketches all the grief they
want in the world but at the end of the
day the finnish manga speaks for itself
because once kite and the team are
enlisted into the ngl zone to
investigate the infestation of chimera
ants the scenarios and encounters they
experience the deeper they go into the
sinister wilderness
the more visually stunning the manga
looks and the more intense the story
becomes
there's honestly a terrific horror
element to this story that what it began
in a much less refined or savory way
evolved much like the monsters
themselves into a more sophisticated
product i'm always thrilled when a manga
can do something creative with its
paneling and tagashi employed a simple
but brilliant choice to kill
his battle in the forest of the ngl zone
alongside kite and gone
after being stung by this scorpion
chimera there's a moment where we think
kilauea could
conceivably be in trouble there's some
quick panels to establish her point of
view and ben
this legitimately got me i was so taken
aback by how takashi perfectly played
with my anticipation to achieve what he
did here
regular or standard paneling is fine but
this is such a great and thoughtful use
of the manga medium that helped drag me
into this story all the more and
fittingly this plays into the greater
mission of this portion of the narrative
to tell a heart-wrenching and compelling
story centered around
gon and kilauea and thankfully this is
helped in part by the surprisingly warm
and engaging character of kite
personally at the beginning of this i
was very worried that he would fall to
the wayside and feel like a one-note
character but tagashi made sure to add
plenty of depth and texture to his
character
whether it be through his position as a
mentor to the two boys our peeks into
his mind as he thinks about how amazing
they really are and we even see that he
has some comedic elements that didn't
contradict or come at the cost of any of
his more serious traits
additionally and this is where the scene
impressed me the most early on it made
full use of kite's character
in the same breath as the chimera ants
so something i've neglected to mention
thus far was how much characterization
and time takashi granted these dangerous
monsters to humanity
so much so that through the process of
getting to know them i
actually started to respect and like
some of the ants with one character in
particular acting as a great grey area
for us
not necessarily due to what he does or
what he says but
where we know those words are coming
from this is clearly a chimera ant that
possesses the mentality or personality
of that protective older brother
killed in the previous scenes and as
this ant is contrasted with the rest of
the chimeras he's in company with that
otherwise we're made up of criminals
that met a similar fate
it helps to highlight thematically a
rather strong message of this arc
it's not what they look like that
defines who they are it's what they do
with that power
and given what later happens in this arc
i'm wondering what sort of mirror this
philosophy will hold
up to the main cast if they are forced
to act upon
morally ambiguous impulses and now with
both sides of the conflict thoroughly
explored with their nuances expressed we
are greeted by one of the most
surprising and shocking scenes i've
ever read in my life
i've spoken from the beginning of this
story expressing my impressions
of gon's mindset and the contrast he
creates with kilauea that they are both
two extreme ends of what could
ultimately be the same
sort of person gone being one to throw
caution to the wind and to always give
everything he has no matter what
and kilauea someone that when forced
with an unsure situation
runs and in this scene this dynamic is
on display
side by side for all to see
as the three of them venture deeper and
deeper into the forest in search of the
nest hopefully in an effort to eliminate
these ants
kite kilauea and gone are stopped in
their tracks as kite senses an
approaching enemy on top of this proving
to be a terrific crescendo to the ever
building tension over the last while it
also made me leap from my seat in
excitement as
every single atom of this encounter was
informed by character
kite's mentor role pito's determination
to seek out those with men
gone's readiness to fight despite what
kite said and killer was immediately
knocking out of his best friend
for his own safety i mentioned in my
attack on titan video momentarily that
one of the best attributes different
scenes can offer
is the question without an answer if all
your characters behave and act
rationally without any flaws and never
make any mistakes then you have a
boring scene there's no texture there
there's no interest however when you add
that uncertainty to a scenario you get a
scene
riddled with what-ifs what if kilowatt
chose to stay
what if gone managed to avoid killer was
attack what if kite got a better weapon
what if
what if what if this was the chapter i
had to take a break for and during the
break my mind was left spinning trying
to determine who in fact was
in the right here hunter hunter has gone
out of its way to almost parody
in every opportunity the shonen genre as
a whole and
in this scene the most shonen event took
place
but the heroes retreated and we weren't
certain if that was the right decision
highlighting once more kilaueangan's
greatest flaws
which just so happened to be what this
arc is about
additionally something else which i
think is noteworthy has to be kait's
demise here and now
in the manga this is a massive
subversion both for gon
and us as the readers introduced to him
in the first chapter while this is a
reunion of sorts
kite primarily is someone that set the
foundation for the gone character we see
today
and when we see him get torn away from
us we're
left speechless surely this couldn't
have happened just like this
not after all this time we've waited to
see him surely he could still be alive
and well and
while riding that wave of hope tagashi
takes full advantage of our perspective
by placing some truly horrific imagery
of kite's disembodied head
on the lap of pito and while i mentioned
this briefly last week
i do think it's worth mentioning one
more time in this instance the 2011
anime
omitted this scene and as a result
robbed it of the weight the manga
otherwise
gave it by design in the manga he's one
of the first characters we're introduced
to
he helps to inform who gone eventually
becomes and the reunion we get to enjoy
between the two characters is
bitterly brief but in the anime he just
for all intents and purposes despite the
retroactive integration
is very much a new character that shows
up to just die
the exhaustion kilauea exhibits from
carrying guns unconscious
limp carcass all the way back to the
entrance shows just how
fast and hard he tried to get out of
there this kid was terrified
all the training they went through all
that they've overcome throughout this
story
seeing that look on kilowatt's face and
the exhaustion he felt after simply
running really puts into perspective the
mindset he was in as well as helps to
amplify
my intimidation towards these new
antagonists all the more this is
incredibly effective and potent
storytelling and with my mind now
fixated on kilauea thinking back to his
quitting of the ball game against netero
in the first arc
we jeez speak of the devil it's natero
your boy got sponsored by g fuel dude
that's awesome
like this is a huge deal and they sent
me tons of creative flavors i mean
do you want to try some yeah totally
what kind of flavors did they give you
well they've got strawberry lemonade
dude seriously like this is a really big
deal for me i mean
like if i don't do a good job with the
sponsorship
the g field monster might come what's
the
g fuel monster
listen the stories surrounding g fuel
are as old as they are terrifying
everyone seems to be convinced that she
feels some zero sugar caffeine free
alternative to other energy drinks on
the market
but in reality this substance might deep
within the earth's core
comes with a deep and sinister curse
curse why is
my dear boy if you never really stop to
consider
the
[Music]
ghosts
is
[Music]
what you said
[Applause]
[Music]
initially i worried over this section
possibly feeling like another waiting
period however upon closer inspection it
precisely focuses on some of the most
interesting
and fleshed out elements of this entire
series
the two boys while the chimera ants are
the titular antagonists that are very
much there to facilitate these moments
of character reflection in this tale
without them without this unknown
powerful force shrouded in mystery
unaware of where they exactly are how
many there are
or whether or not kite will ever return
it prays with surgical
precision on the issues gone and killer
will face personally
[Music]
this scene was viciously interesting
nitero someone that once upon a time
would only speak lightheartedly and with
positive vibes over different subject
matter is
firm in this scene once again aiding in
the effort to create a sense of unease
and chaos around the situation
implying perhaps covertly that he may
very well think that gon and kilauea are
valuable but in kilowatt's case
he sees serious issue one that has been
a recurring theme with kilauea since the
very beginning of this series
his lack of tenacity
i think what i found most interesting
when reading the tarot's analysis of
this situation wasn't what he said but
what he didn't say and ultimately my
wondering over
why he never said it and that
specifically concerns
gon and his shortcomings natero
throughout this exchange seemed to
fixate exclusively on kilauea's issues
and this is the brilliance of this scene
kilowatt very much
does have issues and i think they are
much more pronounced and therefore
clearer to others
when he engages with people however gon
seemingly suicidal disregard for himself
and
under the right circumstances others
around him have played a significant
role in this series too from as early as
the first
arc but all of those instances or
shortcomings
seem to be much more closely linked to
tenacity or perhaps more dangerously can
masquerade as tenacity
and so the latter makes me wonder does
natero know
of that poison in gone he's coaching
kilauea and does make clear his flaws
and while what he says is interesting
and worth thinking about for killua
i think is what he doesn't say to gone
that made the most noise in my mind if
even the tarot isn't aware of it or
doesn't consider it a pressing issue is
netero's direction
focused on the right someone for right
as he finishes out in kilauea's issues
and the two boys are sent on their way
to overcome the set of tests in the next
town we smash cut to an image of kite's
decapitated head
resting on pito's lap and it did that
all to possibly subvert the message or
instruction the terror outlined to prove
the point that gone could
also be nuts and that killua made the
exact right call in that moment
considering natero didn't know the scale
of the situation
which again plays into that very
philosophy i adore in writing
offered by pete docter from pixar it's
that struggle with no answer
that makes for the best stories and that
quote is pertinent because
as an audience we have perhaps the best
insight into this encounter and
i don't know about you but it doesn't
seem nearly as clean-cut as natero is
making it out to be
kilowatt does have this issue in him for
certain but perhaps
in this instance he did the right thing
geez i love this story it's so
complicated and it's so detailed it's so
nuanced and i
it's amazing alright so this section of
the story we're about to embark upon is
set up to once again be a very
stereotypical
shown in subplot wherein the two main
characters offer themselves over to a
wonderful master in this case biscuit in
order to overcome the challenge of
collecting their opponent's tiles so as
to qualify to help with the chimera and
problem before the king is born
and in case natero and the other more
advanced hunters need assistance
and before pam cuts them into little
pieces
this could very well be the most unshown
in training arc
i think i've ever seen the boys are made
to understand their circumstances
understand what's at stake what they
need to do and then they fail
hard and i'm here for it i love that
decision
in this training section the two boys
fail in their assignment but in doing so
i think they learned the exact lessons
they needed to
or at least one of them does and
interestingly despite the vast majority
of hiccups they come
out on top in the end oh well okay not
really but it's okay sort of but
alright let's take a look at this
because it might be the highlight of the
art for me
so far once we get to this town the two
boys must train and we're immediately
introduced to this
charming character called pam she
she is depicted in just the most
horrific way
like she looks like what would happen if
you combine sally from the nightmare
before christmas with a dementor from
harry potter her bloodthirsty eagerness
to participate in this effort with
nonterror is honestly hilarious
her straightforward brutal honesty in
the face of the boy's lack of
development or
progress really leads her to deliver
some of the most dry and hilarious
threats on their lives
contrasted beautifully with guns
kind-hearted and oblivious nature
in the manga so many of her shots depict
her with this wild
jet black hair totally obscuring her
face with the only visible discerning
feature
being her piercing white eyes that cut
through the darkness like a wild animal
caught in the headlights i'm not
entirely sure what sort of role this
character will play in the long run but
at the moment she's here to act as a
threat as i said to the two boys if they
failed but
primarily also a comedic one oh and yeah
biscuits here the two boys at this
moment in time are like
chaos and order side by side too much
chaos is utterly ineffective and too
much order meets pretty much the same
fate but honestly kilauea gets put on
blast in this section quite a bit more
than gon does
in fact a great scene takes place where
even biscuit takes killer with a task
and tells him that either he overcomes
this issue he seems to have trouble with
or
he must leave guns side immediately the
stakes are high for sure but
even then i couldn't help but think why
is no one taking gun to task about his
issue nearly as harshly
and then this happens
so all the while we are watching the
boys slowly progress and try to perfect
their name in order to overcome their
targets knuckle and shoot
we have the stakes get worse and worse
and worse
elsewhere and interestingly this is
where this side of the conflict starts
to come into its own for the longest
time this section was just about the
emotionless queen making babies and her
offspring running amok gathering more
resources but this time
the king is here alright so uh i get the
feeling this is a long-running and
exhausted joke but
i'm gonna say it anyway this king guy is
such a rip-off design wise of cell and
frieza from dragon ball
but hey uh at least it's scary
furthermore with a now defected ant
letting the tarot know that he has no
chance against this new king
the hype levels rise even further plus
the terror powering up is freaking
awesome
with all of these different elements and
interactions all of this is starting to
feel a lot more like dragon ball and i'm
here for it
alright so look this is the last day
that golden kilowatt can fight them and
qualify to help natero in his effort
with the chimera ants they've gotten a
ton stronger in the last month and now
it is
go time and the battle gon has with
knuckles is phenomenal one that depends
on your knowledge and expectation to
deliver its message
obviously knuckle is an endearing
character and i do love him but i also
love the mechanics of knuckles nine
which force gun to be strategic
and efficient with his movements he
can't rush in it's a great pairing in
combat
killers fight with shoot on the other
hand who forces him to be more direct
and confident in his movements
is also great that fight in particular
has some sublime paneling that captures
the frantic stressed out and
disorganized nature of the encounter
perfectly captures the chaotic cluttered
and uncertain thoughts of kilauea as he
tries to make sense of everything that's
going on it's unlike any fight in the
series and stands out all the more
because of that fact
as it should this is a pivotal moment
for the young one time assassin turned
hunter
to prove to both his mentor and to
himself that he is his own person and
that he
is in control of his life and decisions
not anyone else
and they lose gon now has no nen for a
month due to the after effects of
knuckles nine
and kilowatt in his own mind knows that
he must protect gon ironically while
he's defenseless and
then leave him forever this was such a
remarkable place to leave this story
such a low point and
it's brilliant gone and killerwood did
face off against their respective
targets but they did so while showing
that they both still have the same
problems
gone went headfirst into the battle with
knuckle time and again and while it
proved to be great training
it was the same straightforward and
unflitching approach which proved to be
his downfall in the last encounter
before he was ultimately defeated
and kilowa while he did eventually face
him he did so
at the last possible moment which means
these decisions these two kids made
throughout this maniac could have been
indicators for its ending to us as an
audience if we were paying attention we
could have seen this coming this is
such a brilliant section of the story
and then there's
well this character despite lacking i
assume
any higher soul is very much the heart
and soul of this arc
section she is so damn funny
in this manga but again there's this
weird 22 year old girl now
being pacified with a possible date
and relationship with a 13 year old boy
and gone who happens to be by the way
a real ladies man and i don't know how
to feel about that
but it does help to facilitate one of
the best killable moments in the entire
series
the fight against this random chimera
ant he encounters pushes kilowatt more
than i think
any moment in the series has pushed him
he is
petrified shaking and seemingly not at
all emotionally prepared for this
encounter and i
love this scene for a multitude of
reasons but primarily i love it because
the very love kilauea has for his best
friend in the world
was what made him approach this enemy
without any intel or preparation
and the shot of him shaking and crying
honestly hit me like none other in this
arc but
it's that history that they shared which
allowed him to overcome this serious
issue he had i'm not sure yet what the
transmitter in his brain's knock-on
effects might be
for the series or his brother or how he
will react but but right now
kilauea is an absolute monster this is
going to be fun and
okay i know i hate to leave it here and
break these arcs up like i have been but
with this one specifically there's just
too much to cover in this review alone
so next week i'll be back to continue
this exceptional arc
and while i don't know what's still to
come i do know i'm supremely excited to
share my thoughts on it with you all
next week
see you everyone and thank you all so
much for watching
[Music]
you